mes premiers mots seront pour la
population de l'île verte et de toute
leur famille
nous sommes de tout coeur avec vous dans
ce drame
je suis la situation de très près mon
cabinet me tiens au courant de tous les
développements et de l'évolution de la
situation des ministres sont présents
sur les lieux entre autres aujourd'hui
véronique hivon pour offrir les services
sociaux utile et nécessaire ou aux
familles donc des ministres sont
présents sur les lieux et tout est mis
en oeuvre pour venir en aide aux gens et
aux familles éprouvées
j'en profite également pour vous
annoncer que je quitterais davos demain
en direction du québec afin de me rendre
à l'île verte j'écourte donc ma mission
de 24 heures en raison de cette horrible
tragédie survenue hier